it will only take 40 seconds for this
hacker to penetrate the internal system
of the target company for this he will
make the IT guy open a fishing link time
starts now hello you there hello hi this
is Ken how I help you I was wondering if
uh you can uh take a look at a website
I'm trying to get to it's for a uh big
customer thing I'm working on for Monday
and uh I can't seem to get to the
website for my computer sure uh what's
website I'll see if I can get to it
thanks man I really appreciate the help
I mean it could be a stupid thing I'm
I'm I'm really suck with computers but
uh so it's uh it's it's it's
www. survey that's uh s Ur V
y-
pro.com yeah I got a to open I just put
open and I'm at the S now W okay that's
weird I just hit n working it seems like
it's working fine now awesome I don't
know what you did man but I really
appreciate the help hey no problem that
was easy that was it find this computer
right now think of it as not just his
computer but it's pretty much a downfall
of entire
comp